If the function f(n) is contained in O(g(n)), this means that g(n) grows at least as fast as f(n).
Now this might sound a little more complicated that it actually is.
Let's use some examples to see how functions outgrow each other.
Here I have a graph and is on the x axis and I'm going to draw three functions on this graph.
The first function is called f(n), the second function is called g(n), and the third function is called h(n).
What I would like you to tell me know is which of the following statements is true.
Is f(n) contained in O(g(n))? Is f(n) contained in O(h(n))? Is g(n) contained in O(f(n))?
Is g(n) contained in O(h(n))? Is h(n) contained in O(f(n))? Or is h(n) contained in O(g(n))?
So more than one of these is true and I would like you to check each one that is true.
So every time that this function here outgrows the other function, I would like you to check this box.